i
[Música]
se cumplen 20 años del que es
considerado como el peor atentado
terrorista en eeuu este paso a la
historia como el 11-s ese 11 de
septiembre del 2001 en una soleada
mañana dos aviones comerciales fueron
secuestrados y estrellados contra el
world trade center en la ciudad de nueva
york otro avión fue impactado contra la
sede del pentágono en la ciudad de
washington y un cuarto avión impactó
contra el terreno en una zona rural del
estado de pensilvania el 11-s dejó cerca
de 3000 personas muertas dos mil 753
aproximadamente murieron en el ataque a
las torres gemelas y unas mil 106
permanecen sin ser identificadas de
hecho dos cuerpos fueron identificados
hace un par de semanas si 20 años
después fue un cambio de página en la
historia mundial porque vendrían muchos
acontecimientos a partir de eso buena
parte del planeta apoyó a eeuu en su
lucha contra el terrorismo que llevó a
la invasión de afganistán para capturar
al líder de al-qaeda osama bin laden
quien murió en un operativo en el vecino
pakistán por dos décadas eeuu estuvo
presente en ese país asiático en una
incursión militar que terminó como lo
reporta vamos hace unas semanas en medio
de controversias disgustos y la mirada
atenta del planeta entero que tanto
cambio el planeta es más seguro tras la
lucha contra el terrorismo emprendida
por eeuu en que cambió este país
norteamericano en que cambió medio
oriente en que cambió el mundo musulmán
particularmente irak y afganistán que
hay de los grupos terroristas en la
actualidad el presidente de eeuu joe
biden afirmó que
y va a firmar un decreto que ordena
desclasificar los documentos hasta ahora
secretos sobre la investigación que fue
realizada por el fbi sobre estos ataques
estos podrían darnos muchas luces para
tratar de encontrar algunas respuestas a
tantas preguntas que hay después del 11
de septiembre hoy en el debate de france
24 11-s los atentados que sacudieron el
mundo bienvenidos soy santiago lópez
gonzález y para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a susana mangana directora de
la cátedra de islam de la universidad
católica de uruguay también es analista
política internacional ella se encuentra
en la ciudad de montevideo en la capital
uruguaya también está con nosotros
richard downie él es el militar retirado
del ejército de eeuu experto en
seguridad internacional y doctor en
relaciones internacionales él se
encuentra en redondo beach en el estado
de california y aquí en el estudio de
france 24 me acompaña caroline alarcón
antropóloga y docente colombiana se
encuentra conmigo aquí en el estudio
bienvenidos a los tres ustedes también
los televidentes son parte de esta
conversación a través de las redes
sociales ustedes pueden dejar sus
comentarios también todas sus preguntas
sus inquietudes en las cuentas de
facebook del twitter y de instagram
estamos como france24
bajo ese arroba sant y luego que es mi
cuenta personal deje los comentarios con
el numeral el debate efe 24 también hay
una encuesta en línea en este momento
para que ustedes dejen sus impresiones
la pregunta está relacionada con que
estaban haciendo ustedes cuando
ocurrieron los ataques del 11 de
septiembre en la ciudad de nueva york es
sin duda un momento que todos recordamos
todos los que tenemos memoria recordamos
en detalle en que estábamos haciendo en
ese momento ese día a esa hora pues
vamos a comenzar entonces con el debate
comienza que en el estudio con caroline
es gracias por estar con nosotros aquí
en el estudio y cómo cambió el mundo
desde entonces yo ya mencionaba que
comenzó una nueva página en la historia
de la humanidad como lo vio usted bueno
buenas noches santiago y tres gracias
por la invitación y respondiendo la
pregunta de la encuesta yo estaba en la
universidad nacional cuando sucedieron
los ataques lo recuerdo claramente y en
ese entonces no era musulmana
precisamente fueron los ataques las que
me llevaron me condujeron a conocer del
islam y creo que eso pasó mucho en el
mundo musulmán y tuvimos un gran aumento
de las personas que fueron a mezquitas
que fueron a lugares hoy en día se
encuentran muchos testimonios de
musulmanes que fueron buscando hasta
venganza en algunos casos en eeuu y
terminaron siendo musulmanes o
terminaron por lo menos conociendo más
de la religión entonces para nosotros
como comunidad cambio en el aumento que
tuvimos y como en ese contacto que
pudimos establecer con ese otro mundo
que en ese momento era desconocido no
muchos de nosotros no hemos escuchado
nada sobre el islam o sobre el mundo
musulmán antes del ataque del 11 de
septiembre entonces digamos que hubo un
diálogo posterior a eso quien mucho de
muchas maneras en reclusión e
intercambio de civilizaciones
a américa latina y para nuestro
continente americano es una religión que
no es muy común no es la religión
predominante y es una cultura tal vez
muy lejana por la historia que hemos
tenido por la influencia más europea y
de otras zonas del mundo y tal vez por
eso el contacto se ha demorado en
suceder o no es tan extenso o tan
extendido como se ha sucedido con otras
religiones pasó a preguntarle a susana
su punto de vista si en la capital
uruguaya como cambió el mundo desde
entonces desde entonces desde su
perspectiva susana
bueno yo creo que el 11 de septiembre
buenas noches santiago un gusto
compartir contigo y con los compañeros
contertulios y con toda la audiencia
creo que realmente se construyó un nuevo
enemigo pero el 11 de septiembre fue un
parteaguas fue un antes y un después de
ese fatídico día de esos atentados en
eeuu y creo que cambió plenamente el
concepto de las relaciones
internacionales pero también a nivel de
relaciones humanas no todo lo que
significó luego el término seguridad
transnacional
y para richard downie en redondo beach
en california a sus impresiones como
cambió el mundo a partir de esa fecha
muchas gracias santiago es un placer
estar con usted y los otros compañeros
no es de verdad fue un episodio terrible
para para que éstos sepan este ataque el
9/11 fue la primera vez que se había
atacado eeuu desde la segunda guerra
mundial en el ataque contra probarlo
entonces fue en el suelo territorio
nuestro fue dramático para nosotros
entonces
hubo una reacción tremenda hubo
como resultado de esas acciones que
nosotros tomamos después
de este ataque hubo éxitos y hubo una
serie de cosas que fueron reconocidos
como fracasos de verdad pero algunas
buenas y algunas cosas malas pero
estamos aquí
paso a preguntarle aquí en el estudio a
caroline se ya no nos contaba que a
partir del 11 de septiembre
comenzó a mostrar su interés por la
religión islámica y por el mundo
musulmán como fue tomado a lo largo de
estos de estos 20 años
este tipo de acontecimientos sucedidos
en nuevayork vistos por la comunidad
internacional como un atentado
terrorista como se ve desde la comunidad
musulmana bueno pues ciertamente fue muy
duro en especial para los hermanos que
vivían en eeuu
se ha retratado mucho en películas de
pronto en mi nombre ya no se muestra
mucho como tuvieron que dejar de usar el
hiyab la barba muchas de las formas que
mostraban exteriormente que era
musulmanes para evitar ataques
definitivamente cambió para muchas cosas
porque las mezquitas por ejemplo
cambiaron su forma ya no se buscaban
construir con minaretes o con forma de
la mezquita tradicional oriental sino
más como edificios que pudieran verse
desde afuera muy neutrales porque había
miedo había un miedo real a ser atacados
había un miedo real a que la islamofobia
creció muchísimo y en especial la
islamofobia de género como musulmana
somos más visibles en especial cuando
decidimos usar el hiyab entonces la
islamofobia género creció tanto en
ataques físicos como en discurso y
además en un discurso que sé que
involucra muchas veces un racismo porque
involucra la idea de que los musulmanes
todos vienen de un lejano oriente de un
medio oriente de lugares externos y que
no pertenecen a ciertas comunidades y
pues refuerza la idea que nosotros
digamos pero en mi caso no somos latinos
sino que somos personas ajenas a los
lugares que habitamos y eso digamos
dificulta muchísimo la vivencia de
nuestra religión en todo el continente
no sólo en américa en eeuu sino en todas
las américas porque nos bloquea la
libertad de vivir plenamente sobre todo
en las partes externas de nuestra
religión claro interesante punto de
vista susana en la ciudad de montevideo
le pregunto por el gran protagonista de
esta historia que fue el grupo al qaeda
y su líder osama bin laden 20 años
después ya sabemos obviamente de osama
bin laden falleció en este operativo
militar en pakistán pero en donde está
al qaeda en este momento en el orden del
terrorismo internacional se ha diezmado
qué posición tiene qué tan fuerte está
bueno evidentemente si yo creo que se ha
visto debilitado por estos 20 años de
guerra global contra el terror la
presencia también tan abusiva podríamos
decir hoy después de lo que ha
significado el fracaso de esa
intervención de la coalición de fuerzas
comandadas por eeuu pero no sólo hubo
fuerzas también tropas de estados
integrantes de la otan allí en
afganistán entonces dieron un asestaron
un gran golpe o varapalo a lo que es al
qaeda que todavía tiene sus facciones
por ejemplo en el magreb islámico en el
norte de áfrica o también seguía
operativo hasta hace bien poco por
ejemplo en yemen es decir en aquellos
estados fallidos en aquellos países
donde hay una institucionalidad del
santiago es donde pueden proliferar este
tipo de grupos de insurgentes
evidentemente al qaeda sigue siendo por
lo menos su ideología su modus operandi
sigue siendo un ejemplo a emular por
otros grupos como por ejemplo al shabab
podemos tener en somalia o boko haram en
y lejos de ward y de bajar la guardia
tenemos que estar atentos sobre todo por
lo que significa ahora la llegada otra
vez al poder del grupo
que también secundan este tipo de
ideología que en occidente seguimos
viendo como extremista y yo prefiero
llamar como literal muy rigorista y que
evidentemente hay una línea roja muy
delgada que se cruza muy fácilmente para
empuñar las armas en contra de intereses
occidentales
richard de california en eeuu veinte
años después al qaeda sigue siendo una
amenaza para eeuu pese a que ya han
retirado las tropas de países como irak
como afganistán sigue siendo una amenaza
para este país norteamericano
si nosotros todavía estamos preocupados
por el caída por ejemplo durante las
negociaciones en afganistán corren
talibán uno de los requisitos fue que el
talibán no tenga relación o no ofrezca a
santuario
queda en afganistán por supuesto lo como
hemos visto en las últimas semanas con
la toma de kabul
los talibanes dejaron libre
miles de finalistas inclusive como 2000
de al qaida entonces estamos preocupados
por lo que va a pasar la verdad es que
ya que hemos salido de afganistán la
posibilidad de atacar a los yihadistas
si vayan a
tener un seguimiento ahí va a ser
difícil entonces
es todavía una pregunta muy grande para
nosotros
a ver si el talibán vaya a cumplir con
su promesa o no vamos y vayan al alba a
ser santuario para yihadistas por todos
los partes del mundo o si vayan a
resistir esa posibilidad día
existe una pregunta todavía pero
nosotros si todavía estamos preocupados
no solamente por la posiblemente de un
ataque por parte de al-qaida en
afganistán pero muchos otros partes del
mundo caroline usted me puede dar la
perspectiva del otro lado de la moneda y
es desde el mundo musulmán cómo se ve a
estos grupos como el talibán o como al
qaeda que es pues el
directamente responsable de estos hechos
ocurridos el 11 de septiembre mira
dentro de nosotros ha habido un cambio
muy muy importante y es el debate
interno hace 30 años no se hablaba de
yihad digamos en las mezquitas o algo
así era un tema quien pasaba
desapercibido hoy en día cualquier
musulmán de a pie se sabe la etimología
de la palabra
sabe la diferencia entre yihad mayor
yihad menor y hay un discurso construido
al respecto entonces cuando nosotros
empezamos estos análisis las personas
pueden empezar a tomar posiciones y
empiezan a decir bueno este es musulmán
este no es musulmán yo no lo veo como un
hermano para mí porque es que eso es
importante nosotros tenemos una
hermandad mundial y cuando tú dices
bueno es que al qaeda si es hermano mío
o no eso requiere una posición política
hay una posición como persona y esos
debates están haciendo dentro de la
comunidad como nosotros no tenemos clero
no tenemos una organización centralizada
que diga si son o no son o es si cada
comunidad y casas pequeñas comunidades
son responsables de tomar estas
decisiones y son responsables de guiarse
al respecto la mayoría de nosotros no
estamos de acuerdo con lo que ellos
hacen a mí como mujer como musulmana me
preocupa lo que van a sufrir mis
hermanas bajo el régimen talibán porque
pues es que ya tenemos unos antecedentes
graves no son cualquier cosa que además
niegan nuestros derechos como mujeres
musulmanas excusándose en el islam lo
cual es terrible para nosotras entonces
cuando cuando nos preguntan sobre ellos
yo siempre digo que musulmán tiene
derecho a tener su opinión pero si
estamos trabajando para tener unos
discursos al respecto y sobre todo en
los discursos informados que nos
permitan decidir sobre bases reales
realmente ellos no nos representan no
son lo que somos obviamente y no tenemos
ninguna comunión con ellos a pesar de
que compartamos una religión o no la
compartamos porque depende el me gusta
la palabra que usa la doctora susana
literalismo que ellos usan acerca del
islam y sobre esa línea roja muy delgada
que hay entre nos vamos a las armas a
defender unos intereses o si nos vamos a
las armas es pero a atacar unos
intereses de occidente hay que defender
unos ideales o unos conceptos religiosos
claro porque nosotros estamos en medio
porque nosotros ahí hay un discurso de
medio oriente contra occidente no sólo
tú lo acabas de mencionar por nosotros
somos occidentales nosotros somos hijos
de occidentales nacidos acá y que
representamos en gran parte la cultura y
también somos musulmanes no hablamos de
los musulmanes estadounidenses que están
aún más fuerte en esa línea en medio de
muchas cosas
le pregunto a richard en el estado de
california en eeuu sobre la amenaza
terrorista en la actualidad 20 años
después el terrorismo se ha transformado
lo que vimos el 11 de septiembre fue un
secuestro de los aviones unas personas
entrenadas e incluso el mismo osama bin
laden dijo en su momento que los las
personas que perpetraron estos
secuestros no tenían todavía
conocimiento de que era exactamente lo
que iban a hacer hasta unos minutos
antes cuando ya estaban a bordo en los
aviones
secuestrando y quitando a las
tripulaciones de la cabina para poder
ellos ponerse al mando de los aviones
como ha cambiado el terrorismo hoy en
día es distinto al qaeda o estos grupos
terroristas que hay en el mundo entero
pueden sorprender otra vez al mundo con
ataques similares
en el mundo gracias santiago el el mundo
ha cambiado bastante yo mencioné antes
que después de los ataques del 9/11 hubo
unos éxitos y algunos de esos fueron la
reformación de en nuestro país por
ejemplo de las comunidades de
inteligencia y las de edad de la policía
y las fuerzas de la aplicación de la ley
hay una mejor
en función de la inteligencia entre
estas organizaciones otra
otra ventaja desde entonces fue el
departamento de doblan defensa segura
nacional como decimos nosotros
en que hay una integración más de
inteligencia y esa versión de la
aplicación de la ley y con todas las
precauciones que nosotros tomamos en la
combox y es como cuando nosotros
tratamos de abordar un avión tenemos que
pasar por los detectores metálicos y
todas esas extracciones y hoy en día la
posibilidad es bastante grande es
diferente desde entonces se ha cambiado
pero no es decir que no haya la
posibilidad de que vaya a tener otro
otro ataque de un ser un tipo novato
pero de todos modos o bien en nuestro
país otra forma de terrorismo importante
es el terrorismo doméstico
es esa parte pero
lamentablemente es otra parte que
nosotros tenemos que enfrentar si susana
su opinión sobre esta transformación del
terrorismo este punto que destaca
richard el terrorismo interno y el
terrorismo transnacional por supuesto
que es lo que hemos estado presenciando
a lo largo de estos años
sí correcto sea eeuu tiene un gran
problema con ese terrorismo interno con
los grupos también
extremistas que residen en territorio
estadounidense con el tema de las armas
que prácticamente en cada domicilio en
cada casa estadounidense hay armas por
doquier verdad por lo cual ese es un
problema de la idiosincrasia
norteamericana podríamos decir en cuanto
al terrorismo transnacional tenemos
distintos grupos hoy se asocia ese
terrorismo y el fundamentalismo una
palabra que recordemos nace con las
iglesias protestantes justamente de eeuu
pero se asocia o indefectiblemente con
el mundo musulmán y sin embargo yo
coincido con la la invitada del piso
caroline cuando dice que ellos están en
el medio yo diría las primeras víctimas
del terrorismo transnacional de bas
islamista siguen siendo también
musulmanes es decir tanto en irak como
en siria de otros grupos como por
ejemplo hezbollah o el propio hamás que
también castigan muy duro a sus
poblaciones que hacer entonces en este
momento yo creo que la unión europea
como también otan como el propio eeuu se
encuentra en un poquito
espera de ver qué va a pasar en
afganistán con los talibán y mucho me
temo que la pandemia no ayudó a
reactivar la coordinación entre los
servicios de inteligencia hay un matiz
también lo que ocurrió con el 11-s
golpeó muy duro a eeuu porque por
primera vez se golpeaba al país
todopoderoso al imperio estadounidense
dentro de su propia casa por extranjeros
ellos pudieron blindarse cerrando las
puertas negando visados levantando muros
si se quiere santiago muros también del
corazón que son los peores en derribar
en cambio tenemos un terrorismo home
grown no es decir que está hecho en casa
que se fabrica que se produce en toda
europa con aquellos que son ciudadanos
europeos pero que son de origen musulmán
para el 2050 se espera que en bélgica el
50% de la población santiago sea
musulmana con lo cual allí preocupa
mucho también la radicalización de
jóvenes musulmanes y yo creo que se está
trabajando todavía de manera defectuosa
o insuficiente en la convivialidad entre
musulmanes europeos y eso a mí me
preocupa personalmente
susana ya vamos a tocar este tema pero
quiero
darle por eeuu usted mencionaba hace
unos minutos que eeuu a partir del 11 de
septiembre construyó un enemigo a nivel
internacional y prácticamente la
política de eeuu estuvo enfocada durante
estas dos décadas en afganistán y en
esta guerra contra el terrorismo ahora
quién es el enemigo de eeuu a quien se
va a inventar ahora entonces para seguir
este juego bélico a nivel internacional
bueno justamente yo creo que eeuu ha
perdido con esta intervención
militarmente superior sin lugar a dudas
eeuu al armamento del movimiento talibán
pero ha sido yo creo que fracaso
cultural una derrota no sólo de eeuu
también de occidente recordemos que
españa mi propio país también acompañó
esta aventura bélica en afganistán
hicieron falta cuatro presidentes
norteamericanos billones de euros o
dólares para cambiar unos señores
barbudos por los mismos señores barbudos
durante 20 años no se construyó
educación no se nos invirtió en
construir la paz en afganistán ahora se
han quedado un poco a la espera nos
dicen a ver si van a cumplir con su
promesa realmente es increíble que haya
ese tipo de ingenuidad en la política
exterior estadounidense yo creo que no
no es ingenuidad sino que realmente es
un error de cálculo como lo suelen
llamar ellos cuando uno les pregunta de
frente verdad a hace ya décadas eeuu
quiere mirar hacia la zona de
asia-pacífico pero estaba empantanado en
irak y también en afganistán ahora se ha
producido la retirada parcial de irak
pero sobre todo de afganistán pero
quedan otros conflictos y medio como la
guerra en sirias y sin fin la guerra de
desgaste en yemen entonces habrá que ver
quién va a ser ese nuevo enemigo pero
ahí coincido con el colega richard que
está hablando desde eeuu yo creo que
todavía la amenaza de grupos que
instrumentalizan la fe del islam y que
no actúan de acuerdo a las sagradas
escrituras pero manipulan el buen nombre
de a la verdad y tocan en la fibra
sensible de muchos jóvenes musulmanes
algunos
enajenados de su sociedad otros sin
oportunidades como los propios jóvenes
de afganistán creo que todavía tendremos
que estar atentos a que el viraje va a
tener ese terrorismo de base islamista
caroline ya que me lo escribe france24
susana menciona fibras de jóvenes que
son musulmanes radicalización puso de
ejemplo el caso de bélgica bueno muchos
países de europa francia también ha
vivido en casos de radicalización y de
iu de jóvenes musulmanes incluso durante
la guerra en siria muchos dejaron europa
y se fueron a silvia para compartir con
con el estado islámico y con los
diferentes grupos allí como se entiende
esto desde el lado musulmán desde el
lado de su de su cultura de su religión
estás radicalizaciones y esta respuesta
que será militar en nombre del islam en
nombre de la religión bueno nosotros
hemos estado haciendo mucho debate al
respecto porque hay que entender que las
comunidades en eeuu y en europa son
diferentes que las latinas y las que se
pueden encontrar en áfrica o en asia por
ejemplo la radicalización de los jóvenes
en especial en europa tiene que ver
mucho con el desprecio de esa sociedad
hacia lo que ellos son que son
ciudadanos que crecieron allí que muchos
tienen su ciudadanía es europea pero
además tienen estas raíces de países de
mayoría islámica y no son aceptados en
ningún lado ni en el otro están en unas
medias aguas que no les permiten crear
identidades positivas y al contrario se
refuerzan es hacia lo negativo y hacia
el no hacia él no soy de allí no
pertenezco aquí y buscando una identidad
propia es donde se radicalizan porque
buscando una identidad propia creen que
encontrando un brazo armado o
encontrando un grupo armado pues van a
encontrar grupo social que es lo que
muchos jóvenes necesitan y de lo que
mucho jóvenes carecen por eso hoy en día
las mezquitas en europa se están
enfocando en programas juveniles hay
muchas mezquitas que abrieron canchas de
diferentes deportes entonces están
haciendo muchas actividades que en un
pasado no se hacían porque estamos se
está buscando regresar a esa comunidad
digamos a buscar sus raíces pero de una
manera positiva y desde la
identificación identitaria positiva
nosotros digamos acá en américa latina'
tenemos una migración importante a árabe
que muchos de ellos perdieron sus raíces
no en colombia tenemos migración desde
los años 50 y muchos de estos hijos
inclusive nietos de emigrantes están
regresando a las mezquitas hoy en día
como centros de interés como centros
comunitarios y como centros de formación
porque eso también es importante la
radicalización viene de la ignorancia y
de la ignorancia no solo en las bases
del islam sino de la lengua árabe del
corán de nuestra propia historia cuando
empezamos a recuperar nuestra historia
empezamos a recuperar identidades
positivas y eso es algo muy importante
que estamos creando ahora por ejemplo
nosotros estamos creando ya nuestras
propias narrativas nuevos discursos
libros investigaciones propias no solo
traducciones de lo que se hace en medio
oriente sino de lo que nosotros estamos
produciendo y eso tenemos la esperanza
que le produzca a nuestros hijos a
nuestros nietos unas identidades
latinoamericanas europeas
estadounidenses asiáticas de la que sea
pero de manera positiva y arraigadas en
nuestras tierras sin necesidad de
migración realidad claro y sin necesidad
de emigrar a los países de medio oriente
porque es que para muchos de nosotros
los países de medio oriente no son
nuestras casas no son nuestros hogares
ni tampoco nuestros ancestros claro
richard retoma también otra de las
palabras que dijo susana en su última
intervención sobre este error de cálculo
de eeuu con el retiro de las tropas de
afganistán hay mucha expectativa a nivel
internacional sobre lo que pueda pasar
allí usted lo mencionaba si esto se
puede volver un laboratorio una cuna de
entrenamiento de terroristas a futuro si
esto va a dar cabida a otros grupos que
hay en la región o cómo va a ser
manejado si verdaderamente van a
respetar esos acuerdos y van a respetar
las leyes internacionales un error de
cálculo de eeuu otros
y yo que lo que exige
obviamente hay y hubo y hay muchas
razones buenas para que los estados
unidos fuera
salgan de afganistán y eso fue la
decisión por presidente país si fuera yo
pero yo prefería haber dejado unos
2.500 soldados allí para asesorar hacer
o algún
adiestramiento o algo así pero para él
con el fin de establecer la situación
para que pudiéramos saber de bueno
transferido los ciudadanos y los otros
compañeros de afganistán que trabajaron
por las fuerzas militares durante la
guerra que pudieron haberlos
transferidos a otros países eeuu
a eso yo creo que hubiera sido
preferible pero no fue y ahora estamos
fuera de afganistán lo que preocupa yo
mucho y no solamente dentro de
afganistán pero es es como yo creo que
carolyn se mencionaba antes es que la
inspiración por parte de esa operación
que parecía que el talibán un grupo sin
tecnología sin mucha mucha plata fuego
armas
fueron victoriosos sobre los eeuu un
superpoder eso lo que se ha dado en
todas partes del mundo en donde hay
artistas es inspirar y ofrecer la
oportunidad de reclutar otros otros
terroristas yihadistas que podían
llevar a cabo ataques de esa naturaleza
entonces
yo creo que si tú pudiéramos haber hecho
la salida y una forma más estable más
blanco más planeación planificadas y sin
más de cara o hubiera sido mucho mejor
porque es a lo que pasó esa operación
como pasada lo estábamos sorprendidos
ahora el colapso total será de la tarde
fuerzas de afganistán richard susana
caroline me quedan pocos minutos para
para el cierre del programa richard
puntualmente
qué fallo en eeuu no había evidencia de
estos posibles ataques qué lecciones
aprendió después de este ataque del 11
de septiembre porque hay mucha
especulación en que la casa blanca el
pentágono el fbi y la cia sabían de
estos ataques
lamentablemente es que había sido salido
una un nuevo libro sobre los documentos
de aveska afganistán que mostraron que
durante toda esa época los líderes de
políticos militares sabían que la fuerza
militar de afganistán no tenía la
capacidad que se pronunció que tenían y
no hubo lealtad al gobierno porque el
gobierno a afganistán no habían proveído
sólo los servicios
ni a los esfuerzos militares ni a su
pueblo claro entonces
entonces en la lección aprendida es hay
que ser más realista y ccoo con nuestros
objetivos de tratar de crear una gran
nación me quedan dos minutos para cerrar
el programa susana conclusión desde su
perspectiva que va a seguir de aquí en
adelante que dejó el 11 de septiembre
para la posteridad en eeuu ante el
escenario en el que nos estamos
enfrentando ahora con un afganistán
ahora liderado por el talibán
bueno yo lo que creo es que todavía
persiste una brecha muy grande entre eso
que llamamos de más de alguna manera
simplista mundo occidental y mundo
musulmán o el mundo árabe islámico yo lo
que me gustaría que siguiera de aquí en
más es tomar conciencia de que es
importante apostar a un acercamiento son
2000 millones de musulmanes en el mundo
están presentes en los cinco continentes
tenemos también un islam de corte
latinoamericano es decir personas que
abrazan la fe del islam que se reconocen
como musulmanes como caroline desde
colombia hasta la patagonia pero también
personas que han llegado a nuestro
continente es imperativo que los
conozcamos mejor son las lecciones
aprendidas de lo que ha ocurrido con el
11-s pero también con afganistán es que
es fácil invadir un país conquistarlo
militarmente pero difícil conquistar los
corazones de un pueblo y es ahí donde
tenemos que trabajar en acercar culturas
porque yo contrario a lo que dijiste al
principio pienso que no son tan alejados
a nosotros los musulmanes son la tercera
religión revelada monoteísta y entienden
realmente muchísimas similitudes con las
otras dos religiones a mí acá es
judaísmo y cristianismo solo que
nosotros hemos hecho el divorcio entre
iglesia y estado ellos no pero es
importante a tenderles la mano pero
también saber arrinconar a los
extremistas que son los que realmente
violenta en la escena internacional pero
son por suerte para todos nosotros una
minoría muy ruidosa pero son las
minorías
caroline rápidamente para el cierre de
su conclusión no pues necesitamos a
partir del 11 de septiembre nos mostró
que necesitamos más diálogo más
conocernos entre todos dejar los
estereotipos y dejar de pensar nos en
binomios occidente-oriente hembra macho
y pensar más bien desde la
pluriculturalidad de las de la
multiplicidad de lo que somos para
entablar diálogos de pares y no desde
esos estereotipos que muchas veces nos
formamos todos estamos en todo el aussie
habitamos el planeta
susana richard y carol ann es muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros en
el debate de ustedes muchas gracias por
la sintonía sigan en france 24
[Música]